The peak–end rule is a psychological phenomenon
that occurs when people judge an experience
largely on how they felt at its peak and
its end. There are two reasons for this.
More emotionally intense events
lead to better memories than less
intense events. So if you experience a
drama, the peak is what’s most moving,
and to the mind that’s the
most vivid mental snapshot.
We have a better memory of the
end of a sequence — a phenomena
known as recency bias. If you get to
eat 3 different desserts in a row,
the second dessert forms a new memory that
makes it harder for you to recall the first.
And when you’ve finished all three, your
brain remembers the last one most clearly.
However, the rule does not always work.
As we go into an experience, our expectations
play a lead role. If they are initially not met,
our prediction error can affect our
perception of what’s about to come
next — including the peak. But for now, let’s
assume that everything goes according to plan.
Say you go eat out at a cheap diner,
and your expectations are low. Then,
the memory of your evening will be formed
by the peak and the end. The dry salad,
the bad music, and the dirty bathroom
are long forgotten. Later you might
rate the experience as exceptional. But
what if your expectations are not met?
If you go out to eat at an expensive restaurant,
you can have high expectations. If the initial
experience doesn't meet them, your mind decides
that the place isn’t that good after all,
and you’ll see everything through an overly
critical lens. The peak is discounted,
the end outrageous, and then the
overall experience is rated poorly.
So if expectations are low, the
rule works. If they are high,
it's important that they
are met right at the start.
Evidence for the rule was established
through an experiment in which people
were subjected to an unpleasant
experience in two different ways.
for the same amount of time, but then
kept it there for another 30 seconds,
during which the temperature was raised by
about 1° celsius. The subjects were then
offered the option of which of the two
trials to repeat. And as it turns out,
they were more willing to repeat the second trial,
despite the prolonged exposure to the cold water.
Kahneman, Fredrickson, Schreiber, and Redelmeier,
who conducted the study in 1993,
concluded that "people chose the
long trial simply because they liked the
memory of it better than the alternative”.
If you happen to run a restaurant and
manage to meet your customers expectations,
you can create a wonderful peak, finish
with a fantastic end and deliver an
experience that’s not only excellent,
but will also be remembered as such.
Now what do you think about the rule? And did you
ever make your own peak-end experience? Please
share your thoughts and what you remember
from this video in the comments below!
If you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation,
you can support us. Visit
patreon.com/sprouts. Just visit us,
learn how it works, and what’s in it
for you. We hope to see you there!
And if you are a parent or an educator,
check our website sproutsschools.com.
There you’ll find this and other video lessons,
additional resources, and classroom activities.
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com